You have to see this. A Fox News propagandist
annd former Judge Jeanine Pirro abruptly cut
off an interview because she says she doesn't
tolerate lies on her show. That's beyond it. Like
you can't make an SNL skit out of this because
the real segment is already an SNL skit. Judge
Jeanine was interviewing an immigration attorney
named David Leopold. He's a lawyer with Olmer and
Bernie LLP. And it starts going south when David
Leopold tells the judge that not much of what he's
hearing on her show are facts. And this this
starts to set her off. Take a look to that.
The highest number is because
Biden is sending them in.
Janine, just because I say my
number doesn't mean they're wrong
and you want to talk about about facts. These
are the facts and they're not facts. And very
few things that I hear in the show tonight
have been facts. You said this evening that the
board. All right. Well, David, let me ask you
something. If you don't think anything's been
so, she doesn't like that she starts
shuffling around her papers and such. And
then when David Leopold says, listen, Joe Biden
is actually the one making America great again,
she gets fully triggered, she says
canceled. She's ending the interview because
she does not tolerate lies on her show and
kept his promise. He's putting COGAT relief out
there. He's making America better. He's making
America great again. He is bringing David, I'm
stopping you right there. I don't tolerate lies
on my show. He is bringing covid into this country
after Americans weren't allowed to go to
work, go to church or visit families or go
to funerals. And now he's bringing in a whole
pandemic during a pandemic. David Leopold,
thanks for being here and thanks for nothing.
Thank you. Still ahead, my co-host this
is this is the death of irony. Judge
Janine on Fox News does not tolerate lies.
You can't write this stuff, and she truly
seems flabbergasted and dismayed that someone,
anyone would have the testicular fortitude to call
her out on her own program. Now, my instinct is
that David Leopold is not going to be invited
back to judge Jeanine's program. Notice also
that she didn't even allow a discussion of whether
what he was saying is a fact, which, of course,
Leopold would have been able to defend had he
been given the opportunity. But he was it's all
the stuff that the right says they don't do. She
silenced the battle of ideas and then she canceled
David Leopold. Genuine problems here. Another
media literacy education, epistemology problem
is that in this country, the question of what is a
fact is being debated. Now, I don't mean by that,
that the empirical particulars of facts are being
debated like that would be a debate like, oh,
what is the number of parts per million of carbon
or carbon dioxide in the atmosphere? Right. Like
that. That's we're debating the number, OK? We're
not even debating the relevance or consequences
of a fact. Many people in this country quite
literally don't know what type of statement is
in the realm of an empirical fact, checkable
data point. And what is an opinion in the
anti-tax segment that I played for you earlier,
we heard people being told you can't get the flu
from the flu shot. You can't get covid from the
covid vaccine. That's an empirical question where
we can find it out. Is there evidence of people
getting the flu from the flu shot? But then the
people we saw say this is my view of what is a
fact. People do get the flu from the flu, just
flu shot. We are not in agreement as to what types
of things are facts versus opinion. And of course,
Fox News specializes in that by saying, well, we
have the opinion side and we have the news side,
but they blur it and then they on the news
side report on what the opinion people say
as if they are facts. This is what it leads to.
It leads to exactly this. And I don't think we'll
be seeing David Leopold back on Judge Jeanine's
show. And I know a bunch of people said David,
she seems drunk again. Yeah, I don't know. I
don't know. I know that there's been a number
of episodes where Judge Jeanine just just really
seems drunk. Either way. She's she's a disaster.
It's not I have no idea whether she was or wasn't
drinking. But of the I think eight people sent
me this interview, six said she seems to be drunk
again. Maybe, I don't know. But what she's doing,
the you know, the cancelation of David Leopold I
don't think is based on the amount that she's had
to drink. Let's take a quick break. We'll be
back after this with much more. Occasionally,